hey everyone welcome to this new video
by simply learn this video is dedicated
to backlink building techniques in 2024
but before we begin consider subscribing
to Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us so let's
first begin by understanding how getting
a backlink impacts your website a
website was looking for increased
website traffic and sales for an
e-commerce jewelry business to
accomplish their goals they Incorporated
the following strategies they identify
High da websites in fashion and handmade
Goods Niche engage in collaborations
with blogger influencers and online
Publications actively participated in
social media showcasing products and
engaging with influencers listed
websites on relevant directories and
Industry associations as a result they
saw a significant increase in organic
traffic within 6 months achieved High
High search engine rankings leading to
more visibility expanded reach to New
audiences through collaborations
enhanced brand Authority and credibility
within the industry through strategic
backlink efforts the company
successfully grew its website traffic
improved search engine rankings and
expanded its online presence
demonstrating the effectiveness of
backlinks in driving organic growth so
this has made you a little more curious
to know about backlinks and how to build
backlinks to get increas in traffic and
boosting business before we start by
understanding what is backlink if you
are looking to get certified in 2024
then you are at the right place
introducing per your postgraduate
program in digital marketing which will
be your all over companion with this
program you will as in onpage SEO and
off-page SEO keyword research search
engine optimization behavioral marketing
campaign management social media
marketing content marketing and much
more with these technical expertise you
will also gain complete Hands-On
learning with the tools like Google
Keyword Planner chat GPT Google ads and
Google analytics and there are more than
30 tools in the list reserve your seats
first enroll now from the link in the
description box and pin comment so let's
start by understanding what is backlink
a backlink also known as an inbound link
or incoming link is a hyperlink on one
website that directs users to another
website in simpler terms it is a link
from one web page to another backlinks
are important for search engine
optimization or SEO because they signal
to search engines that other websites
consider your content valuable enough to
link to consider an example here let's
say you run a Blog about healthy recipes
and you have written an article about
benefits of incorporating avocados into
one's diet a popular food blogger comes
across your article and finds it
informative and well researched they
decide to write a blog post about the
healthiest superfoods and include a
hyperlink to your article about avocados
as a reference for their readers now in
this scenario your article about
avocados receives a backlink from a
popular food blogger's website when
users read the food bloggers post and
click the hyperlink they are directed to
your article on healthy avocad
recipes search engines like Google take
a note of this backlink interpreting as
a vote of confidence from the food
bloggers website indicating that your
content is valuable and relevant over
time as you accumulate more backlinks
from reputable websites your own
websites Authority and credibility may
increase in the eyes of search engines
potentially leading to higher rankings
in search results for the relevant
keyword like healthy avocados recipe B
in short backlinks serves as
endorsements or referrals from other
websites contributing to your website SE
efforts and overall online visibility
when a website links to your page it can
use either a do follow or a no follow
link do follow links are advantages for
SEO when a website employs a do follow
link to direct users to your site it
transfers its Authority or link juice to
your website this enhances your website
Authority and positively impacts your
ranking on the other hand no follow
links do not transfer Authority or link
used to your website making them less
beneficial for SEO despite this while
they may not directly influence your
website's ranking no follow links can
still drive user traffic from one
website to
another now that we have understand the
difference between do follow and no
follow links let's explore some of the
strategies used by optimizers to acquire
backlinks to build a backlink there are
majorly four ways you can either ask
earn add or buy a backlink we will
Implement ask earn and add in backlink
building strategies in the upcoming part
of the video however if you choose to
buy a backlink ensure that they are from
the reputable sources and acquired
through the transparent and ethical
means focus on quality over quantity and
prioritizing backlinks from the
authorative websites within your
industry remember remember the most
sustainable and effective way to build a
backlink is through the creation of
valuable content and the cultivation of
genuine relationship within your
industry while asking for backlinks and
occasionally purchasing them can be the
part of your strategy they should
complement your efforts to add and earn
backlinks through high quality content
and ethical practices buying a backlink
can be a black hat practice let's
understand what is white hat and black
hat backlinks in detail white hat back
links are obtained through ethical and
legitimate means following the search
engine guidelines some white hat
techniques includes creating high
quality content guest blogging broken
link building building network with
influencers bloggers and Industry
experts to earn natural backlinks
through genuine relationships and
directory submissions as well talking
about black hat techniques black hat
backlinks are acquired through unethical
and manipulative tactics that violate
search engine guidelines some black hat
techniques are buying back links keyword
stuffing private blog Network link
spamming and more we recommend our
Learners to never to use black hat
techniques as these practices can lead
to penalties and loss of search rankings
so let's move ahead and understand link
building strategies for 2024 number one
craft valuable content develop content
that is informative and engaging
enticing others to link back to it
identify link
opportunities discover websites or blogs
within your Niche that could potentially
link to your content using the tools
like ahrs or Sam Rush engage and connect
reach out to website owners bloggers and
influencers through personalized message
suggesting collaboration possibilities
guest posting offer to contribute guest
post to relevant websites embedding a
backlink within the content create
valuable resources
develop tools or guides that offers in
your industry will find beneficial
encouraging them to link back to your
site leverage social media share your
content on social platform to increase
visibility and encourage linking engage
with influencers to expand your network
submit to directories list your website
on relevant directories to acquire
authoritive backlinks Monitor and manage
keep track of your backlink profile
using tools like Google search console
address any lowquality backlinks
promptly build connections build genuine
connections within your industry through
forums conferences and online
communities opening up natural linking
opportunities stay consistent building
backlinks is an ongoing process
maintaining the consistency in content
Creation Outreach efforts and backlink
management so here are some backlink
building tools that one should look for
while considering link building sem Rush
bus Sumo Hunter and ah riffs these tools
are available in trial as well as paid
versions so here we wrap up this topic
on how to build back links in 2024 if
you like this video hit the like button
and don't forget to subscribe to Simply
learn to never miss any updates from us
thanks for watching staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here